bonjour aller vite retrouver françois il
vous attend
bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes en train
de parler de collection hier tu fais une
collection de quoi une collection pierre
de pièces une collection de pièces et
toi michael
réduction des formidables et toi
françois
des collections de livres hors jury
salue casimir tu vas bien mais non pas
du tout regarde comme je suis pas mal à
n'avait pas remarqué tu es malade non
mais regarde
quoi françois mais oui je ne comprends
pas pourquoi il me déteste et qu'il ne
m'a pas attendu mais il ne te déteste
pas du tout mais alors pourquoi at il
commencé en jeu son mac ordre mais il
n'a pas commencé à je sais françois
pierre et mickaël qui lui ont apporté
leurs collections et justement il
t'attend pour les montrer à nos amis ah
bon c'est vrai oui je vais beaucoup
mieux alors merci je suis en elle et
françois casino que se passe-t-il il est
arrivé un accident mais non mais je suis
là tu peux commencer à montrer les
connexions voyons que du mur c'est vrai
que nous attendions mais nous étions en
pleine discussion et tu nous interrompue
vraiment tu es trop capricieux mon vieux
c'est pas parce que tu arrives que nous
devons commencer à montrer la collection
immédiatement mais ici ah bon et
pourquoi s'il te plaît mais mais parce
que je suis le dernier à venir tout le
monde est là alors qu'il n'a pas traîné
c'est vraiment ce que tu penses ouais
mais alors
que voulez-vous répondre à ça
bon alors on commence oui oui casimir on
y va
hier tu me parles de ta collection
tsr je vais commencer jours s'est
retrouvé dans un grenier carton avec pas
mal de pièces qui étaient assez ancien
je me suis dit que le caisson n'y pensez
pas envoyer souvent ces caisses qui ne
valait plus ou alors on connaissait des
gens qui veut notre pays qui avaient des
pièces dont il se sert le coup alors
j'ai pensé qu'il faut faire une
collection il était venu de faire une
collection de pièces tu sais comme on
appelle une personne qui fait que l'ex
en cassant un numismate a des amis ce
matin montre moi quelques pièces dont il
est très fier d'une qui brille martin
pièces de la peau les os x elle est en
quoi
en bronze y en a d'autres oui ça pèse
particulièrement à une caisse qui
jusqu'au 16 août 7,6 au lit parce qu'il
était très motivé c'est vrai elle et
elle est très très belle maman
elle est très ancienne
tu as des pièces aux grippes récentes
dans la collection
montre là celle ci elle est très jolie
les collections
michael tu me parler de ta collection
le coq a des soucis de feuilles qui se
sont sur du charbon oui charbon bien
facile de feuilles ah oui on voit très
nettement l'empreinte
et celui ci par le mot celui ci je
trouve magnifique
un grand coquillage et il le ter qui
rentrait dedans oui pour un coup là
peu d'étapes thé et petits tacles à la
terre ces faits pierre ému n'a
certainement le coquillage qui était
dessus est parti et puis il reste l
empreinte si vous voyez la collection de
françois maintenant une collection
aussi du pire y
passer ses diplômes du plomb face ils
disent pas que la fille du dentifrice
oui qu'est-ce que tu as qui t'intéresse
particulièrement dans taxer les quartz à
toutes les pièces se plaisent je pense
ça c'est du quartz
et du lait tu les trouves commenter les
pierres
des fois toutes les offres ou des fois
oui dans le monde où il est rouge des
fois quand
elle montre ses formes courtes des
pierres ont toujours vive on les prend
et qu'est ce qui t'intéresse dans le
fait de faire une collection
c'est joli c'est joli et puis on apprend
jetant soucie énormément de choses sur
la nature bien voilà trois collections
fort belle vous êtes de grands
collectionneurs
je félicite
at war oui tu viens de dire à pierre la
france prend et mickaël ils étaient des
grands collectionneurs mais existe-t-il
des très grands collectionneurs que tu
dire que c'est bien un grand
collectionneur est un grand
collectionneur mais un très grand
collectionneur et un collectionneur plus
grand qu'un grand collectionneur
attaque
très grave dire plus grand que
grand'mère tu as tout à fait raison
normand barre alors tu n'as pas répondu
à ma question existe-t-il des très
grands collectionneurs pardon ah mais
oui bien sûr qu'ils y mourir selon alors
ils vont bien existé là le plus grand
collectionneur du monde c'est certain
bon
j'aurais que fier de le connaître
évidemment qu'il connaît non pas encore
mais je crois quand je le connais très
bientôt
[Musique]
bonjour
il faut que je cache ceci avant que
julie et françois ne le vois
je vais le mettre dans la dans la malle
magique
voilà je ne peux pas vous montrer pour
l'instant mais vous le verrez tout à
l'heure un
voile à
julie bonjour papa casimir mon jour mais
on sait déjà vu tout à l'heure un oui
c'est vrai
1 qu'est ce que tu cherches à attraper à
à le bocal de caramel non non non non
j'en veux bien mais ce n'est pas ce que
je cherchais à attraper ma bon mais
alors qu'est ce que tu vas et bien
dovima
bonbons fourrés à la framboise c'est pas
ça non alors c'est délicieux sucre
d'orge non non plus et bien alors je ne
sais pas moi une trajet au point pas du
tout écoute casimir je donne ma langue
au chat je n'ai pas le temps de jouer
aux devinettes je travaille des coûts du
lille et là je vais te le dire à
l'oreille alors j'écoute et voilà la
réponse mais vos boutons mais tu es fou
taïmyr
très bons boutons est quasi vide enfin
ça alors c'est c'est incroyable
[Musique]
mais que se passe et je me tue c'est
françois si tu savais ce que casimir
vient de me faire mais mais tu sais tu
ce ne sont pas deux comme c'est joli
mais je crois que tu es perdu un butin
oui je vais pas pk casimir qui me l'a
arraché il ne s'est pas excusé de cette
malade roms c'est pas une maladresse il
l'a fait exprès exprès oui mais pourquoi
le pire c'est que je ne le sais pas non
mais je ne lui demanderai des comptes
mois il faudra bien qu'il me donne une
explication essaie de récupérer un bon
bouton - d'accord
kazim
je voudrais que parler casimir en soit
je voulais justement peu fois la touche
au domaine des boutons s'il te plaît
mais pourquoi et parce que je n'ai pas
envie que tu m'as rachat bhutto comme tu
l'as fait à julie charbon je crois que
je vais avoir du mal à lui prendre un
bouton mais mais je me dis qu'elle est
meilleure écoute qu'est ce que c'est
pour excuse moi françois mais c'est un
terrible malentendu je n'ai pas fait
exprès dans d'arracher un bouton à julie
pourtant d'après ce qu'il a dit mais je
t'assure écoute je vais te montrer
exactement comment ça s'est passé oui tu
as raison avant de seconde et je dois te
permettre de t'expliquer françois tu
vraiment mon meilleur ami
donne moi ton explication alors voilà
tiens toi bien droit les bras le long du
corps pour quoi faire
ah ben une reconstitution pour te
montrer exactement comment à l'état il
faut que tu sois dans la même position
que tu as tout à fait raison mais on ne
bouge plus comme ça ça va me voilà donc
je me suis approchée doucement de julie
et hop je viens arracher son bouton
quinzaine d'août ou et casimir le tu es
fou ahaha bravo c'est une très bonne
reconstitution ça exactement ce que
julie manille
mes amis je suis content de vous voir il
se passe des choses très graves dans
l'île aux enfants raconte édith recteur
c'est bien mais pas aux amis casimir est
devenu fou d'où je viens de parcourir
l'île pour ma tournée je n'ai rencontré
que des gens des gens affolés
casimir les avait attaqués oui pour la
hanche et un bouton de leur veste ou de
leur robe regard des facteurs eaux
commencent à me à vous aussi la house et
on sent leur tracteur bourgeois ne pense
pas que c'est bien la proche forêt draf
facteurs je ne voudrais pas d'un enfant
mais que j'aimerais que vous regardiez
un orage ô qu'il enlevait les oiseaux où
est
mon bouton casino charlot j'ai honte
d'être ton ami mais pourquoi en france
mais au contraire tu devrais fier de moi
fier on a sûrement pas mais si tu as
bien dit tout à l'heure que tu aimerais
rencontrer le plus grand collectionneur
du monde
et bien voilà je suis le plus grand
collectionneur de moutons du monde
azimi
[Musique]